ANKUR KOTWAL: Hi everyone.
Welcome to another Android
Developer Lab+.
We're in a different day
of the week today.
It's obviously not a Thursday.
Unless of course you're watching
on YouTube, in which
case it might be.
You might be in the future.
Anyway, so welcome.
We are actually coming to you
today from Hong Kong.
So even though Tony and I are
on different screens, we are
actually right opposite
one another.
I'll let Tony introduce
himself.
TONY CHAN: All right.
Hi, everyone.
My name's Tony.
So Ankur and I today
are in Hong Kong.
So cool.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: All right.
I'm Anirudh, and
I'm [INAUDIBLE]
joining from Hyderabad.
And [INAUDIBLE]
here, I guess.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Anyway, so
thanks for joining us.
I'm Ankur Kotwal.
Normally from the Sydney office,
but I'm glad to be
here with Tony for once.
So today's topic of the week
is actually the native
development kit.
And we have our resident expert
Anirudh who's going to
present that to us.
So take it away, Anirudh.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: All right.
Thanks, Ankur.
Let me share my slides.
OK.
Can you all see the slides?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
All right.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: So the topic
for today is NDK.
I'm going to introduce
to you what is NDK.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Anirudh,
sorry to disturb you.
We can see Keynote.
We don't see the presentation
itself.
I think you might have screen
shared only Keynote.
You need to screen share your
desktop in order for the
actual presentation to show.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: OK.
I'm going to do it
another way.
ANKUR KOTWAL: All right.
So while Anirudh does that--
the NDK is obviously an
alternative to using Eclipse
and doing Java programming.
And--
well, I don't want to steal
Anirudh's thunder.
So go ahead, Anirudh.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: All right.
So everything's fine now?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: All right.
Thanks.
So first, what is NDK?
It's the Native Development Kit,
which basically means it
allows you to build and publish
native applications--
build and deploy,
I should say.
So it's actually a tool set, a
collection of tools, which
includes cross toolchains like
the compiler, linker, and
build system for native
libraries, which you use to
write your C/C++ code, link
them against the libraries
available as part
of the system--
ABI, binary interface, as well
as the other libraries--
and include them as part of the
Android build system so
that they get packaged
into your APKs.
And we also have a build system
which uses Android.mk,
the Android make files.
And this is what you use to
build your native libraries.
Then, like I mentioned, there
are packaging tools available.
So that when you actually add
a native library to your
project, which also contains
Java code and Android
manifests and other
activities.
It allows you to bundle
your native libraries
along with your APK.
So that you can deploy them
to the [? cluster. ?]
And the part that I mentioned
about ABI, which is the binary
interface or the headers,
these are basically the
headers available from the--
C/C++ headers and libraries
available from the Android
framework to you to
code against.
And there are a lot of things
about these libraries that you
should know.
And we're going to look at some
of the basic architecture
of how all these components are
deployed, so you better
understand what these libraries
are and why these
are the only libraries
you should use.
So before we begin looking
into the libraries and
architecture, I want to
cover what NDK is not.
And this is very important.
There are some--
people have asked
us questions.
Is NDK a replacement for SDK?
Or can I just write my
code in C/C++ because
I'm better at it?
So NDK is not a replacement
for SDK.
SDK always will be the primary
choice of development platform
for Android.
And it offers you tons of
libraries through the Dalvik.
The SDK is the primary platform
for development.
NDK is only targeted
for special cases.
And we're going to discuss
what those cases are.
NDK is not the solution for
performance issues.
So if you have performance
issues in your app, do not
think that if I use C/C++
code with NDK, my app
is going to be faster.
For most applications, NDK will
not make a difference.
And Dalvik is actually very
optimized and employs you with
all the many--
garbage collection stuff,
which you'll have to do
manually when writing
native code.
So it's not always a solution
for performance issues.
It's not meant for typical
applications.
So if you have a regular UI,
list view kind of application
where you're pulling data from
the internet and storing them
on data store and showing
them on UI and
letting the user interact--
these are your typical
applications.
NDK is not meant for those.
And it's not an alternative
programming language option,
which means that you cannot
choose NDK just because you're
comfortable with C/C++.
But you have to be comfortable
if you choose NDK for specific
needs of your project because
all the code is done in C and
C++ and [INAUDIBLE].
So now, when to use NDK?
So if you have a lot of
libraries that you've written
as part of your projects or open
source libraries that you
would like to use--
we use these native
libraries--
you should use NDK.
So while you can still write
your application code in Java,
you can actually include these
libraries and make those
[? generate ?]
codes across from Dalvik to
the native [? world. ?]
And in that sense, use
these libraries
that you already have.
Also, if you are writing
something that is
computationally intensive--
for example, a lot of
math is involved--
you can look at the option
of using NDK.
Because with NDK you can
leverage some of the CP
specific extensions for
performance, like vector
floating point instructions
and NEON instructions.
And these are really fast
routines that you can access
directly from NDK.
So this may be a case where you
can look to use NDK if you
feel that that last bit of
performance, you need to
squeeze out from the platform.
So we're going to look at
some of the supported
platforms right now.
So we support the ARMv5
instructions set, ARMv7 with
the hardware floating point
unit, Thumb-2, and Neon
instructions.
Then we also support x86
architecture and MPS.
So what this means is basically
you can use NDK to
build libraries or shared
objects for
these platforms only.
So your code has to run on one
of these platforms because the
[? binary's ?]
generated and kept
in a folder.
And all of these specific
platforms are available to you
right now to generate
those libraries.
So let's look at an
architectural overview where
NDK and where the different
components sit in the system.
So if you're a Java developer,
you've actually
used Java SDK before.
You can see, there is a
Linux kernel there.
And then we have a Runtime,
the Dalvik VM.
And then you have all these
framework classes and APIs and
stuff available to you
that's [INAUDIBLE]
on top of the Runtime.
And these are activity managers
of the entire Android
framework that's available
in the SDK.
And then you write your
applications on top of this.
So the Runtime is talking to the
kernel using JNI, which is
Java Native Interface.
So you can call C/C++ native
code from Java Runtime.
But--
so what happens is that there
are certain systems that are
really sitting on top
of Linux kernel.
And that's where what I
mentioned about a certain set
of headers and libraries
available to you as an NDK
programmer.
The reason why that is so is
because a lot of the system
libraries that we have
that are running
on top of the kernel--
these are not very stable.
And there's no reason for
them to be stable.
We change them across versions
as we see fit.
And we cannot really guarantee
a stable interface on top of
this because this is something
that only Android uses.
And it's meant for only Android
framework and Runtime.
So why release different
versions?
We can make sure our Runtime
adapts to these changes in the
system libraries.
But that's not something
we'd like to tell
you with your apps.
Because then if you have a new
release of the framework, a
new API SDK release, your apps
will start breaking if you're
using any of those system
libraries that have changed
over the version.
So what we try to do is provide
you a stable ABI, the
Application Binary Interface.
And this is a set of headers
and libraries that are
available to you to
code against.
So we make sure that
these are stable.
These remain the same over
different versions of NDK.
So you can always rely on--
it's kind of guaranteed that
they will work across.
And the box that you see that
says Libraries, these are your
libraries, the libraries that
you write on top of these
stable ABIs.
And then again you can
use JNIWrapper.
And your applications can have
Java code that can directly
talk to your libraries
that are talking to
stable ABIs using JNI.
So this is an alternative code
execution environment that
basically is what
NDK provides.
So some of the headers that
are available to you--
I guess this is pretty
much all the headers
available to you.
And this is what you
should be using.
So the first one is libc.
I think I have a mistake
there saying lib.
It's libc, the standard
C library.
And there's a lib math, the
lib compression library;
liblog, it's [? just the ?]
Android log system, if you want
to interact with that;
the libdl, dynamic
linking library.
And then we have graphics native
libraries like OpenGL,
ES1.1, 2.0 spec libraries, and
libjnigraphics that can talk
directly to the rendering system
like bitmaps and stuff
and also to the OpenGL stuff.
So these are the libraries
available to you.
And recently, with
Gingerbread--
well, not so recently.
With Gingerbread we added
support for more libraries to
basically cater to the needs
of game developers.
And so there is OpenGL ES
Audio available to you.
There is libegl available
to you.
And also a standard C++ library
is available to you.
So these are the only headers
and libraries you should use
in your program from the system
and not rely on any
other system libraries available
because they may not
remain the same.
So it's very important to note
that if you want to support
your application across
versions, just stick to this
set of libraries.
So how do you write
a simple app?
So in terms of project
structure, it's pretty much
the same when you create
a project.
And you can do that by using
either Android create project
script that is available
or use [INAUDIBLE]
project.
And you have a folder called
JNI that [INAUDIBLE]
to your source and to
your libs folder.
This JNI folder is actually
written in the NDK code or
your native code.
So you write your C/C++
library source files.
And these may actually be
another project that you
already have.
And you can just place all that
C/C++ code inside this
JNI folder.
And then you write a bare
file, Android.mk file.
And the syntax is pretty easy,
and it's very flexible.
So this is-- what you need to
do to build your NDK code is
write the Android.mk file.
In this file you basically
describe where are your source
files, what source files you
need to build, what are the
libraries these source files
should link against, and the
output of the library.
This is for modules.
If in your project you're going
to have more than a
couple of modules or native
libraries that you're
building, you will have
an Android.mk
file for each of those.
And then on top of that, you'll
have an Application.mk
which is basically a wrap,
something that is going to
dedicate the module building
for each of
these Android.mk files.
So use the Application.mk
to build all of
these Android.mk files.
Optionally, you can use javah
or Eclipse tools, IDE tools,
to generate C headers
from Java files.
So if you're--
which in general, we introduce
something [INAUDIBLE]
and we'll get over there.
But before that if you're
writing code for all the
platforms, what you want to do
is-- in your Java code, your
application code, you have some
methods incremented there
and some methods or something
that you want to use in the
other platform.
So you're going to prefix the
keyword method in front of
those methods in Java.
And then you can use javah to
generate the headers for these
Java files, which actually
generates a [INAUDIBLE] code,
which you can use to interact
between Java and the Dalvik at
the native [? world. ?]
So once you do this step-- and
this is optional, depending on
your use case--
you would run the NDK build
script which is available.
And this is the entire toolchain
available to you.
So you would run this NDK
[? tools ?] to generate new
native, share object,
or library.
And in your Java code, you can
load this library by saying
system.loadLibrary, native.so
or whatever the name
for your module is.
And NDK build is part of the
entire NDK platform, which is
available for you to download.
And it's platform specific.
So this is something you can
go and download from
developers.google.com.
Just along with the SDK,
you can find the
NDK links to that.
So once you've generated the
shared object libraries, and
system.loadLibrary will make
these libraries available to
you loaded dynamically against
the running application.
So with Gingerbread, we
introduced something called
NativeActivity.
So before Gingerbread, you would
always need to have some
Java code in your application
and some specific methods
implemented in native code.
So you would--
like I said, you would put the
native prefix in front of
those methods.
So you would say private,
native, and do this, something
in [? past ?] parameters.
So with Gingerbread,
you can actually
write Java-less classes.
And you can-- still my entire
activity is a NativeActivity,
so you don't have to write
any application code.
And this is something
useful for game
developers and something.
So if you're a game developer,
and you have all your input
and your UI and everything
written in native code, you
really don't need any Java
interface to it.
So what you can do is write
a NativeActivity.
So like I mentioned, it
implements a complete activity
in native code.
So we'll just look at the
manifest of how you declare a
NativeActicity.
So if you see, in this slide
there is an activity by the
name of
android.app.nativeactivity.
And this is the activity tag,
which has an element called
metadata, which specifies
the name of a library.
And this is the native library
we are going to be using.
And the value is the
activity name, the
NativeActivity available.
So this will actually make
sure that your activity--
this will tell the Android
Runtime that there is no Java
class for this activity.
The entire activity is
implemented natively.
And if your application is
completely Java-less, you
would see that in the
application path we have
something called
Android:hasCode="false", which
means that there is
no Java code.
And all the components inside
this APK are native.
So the entry point for
a NativeActivity--
if you're writing a native app
activity completely Java-less,
the entry point is
android_main.
So in your C/C++ you should
have this entry point.
And this is where the Runtime
starts interacting with your
application.
[INAUDIBLE]
and this is kind of similar to
the Android activity style.
This is implemented as part
of Android native [? gu ?]
library.
And this is something you will
have to link against when
you're building your
native code.
So when I mentioned Android.mk
files where you define your
dependencies in the libraries,
you would also have to include
this library.
So before we discuss tools and
IDEs, there are some important
performance considerations
with the NDK.
So when you're actually--
the first thing is the threads
that are created in your
applications are tied
to the process.
So sometimes your activity may
stop or may pause, but your
thread and your process
is still alive.
That's actually hosting
these activities.
That's your application, which
sponsor Dalvik VM.
So this process must
still be alive.
So because the process may be
alive, you're using threads in
your NDK code, your threads will
also continue running.
So it's something important you
should know when you're
writing your application.
Although the activity may be out
of the screen or may have
been paused because some dialog
popped up in front,
your threads will still
be running.
Sometimes you want to choose
which threads you should stop
at that point of time
or which threads
you should keep running.
So if you're doing some kind of
sound, maybe something you
want to stop there.
Because once your activities
are stopped or paused, you
don't want to hear any sound
from your application.
But there are other things
that you may
need to keep running.
So that's an important
consideration when writing NDK
code, native code.
The other thing is because
the process is only
[? brought live ?]
once, there may be some static
initializers in your code and
they will all be getting
initialized once.
So the activity stops and
then again resumes.
These static initializers will
not be loaded again, so you
may want to avoid the static
initializers and take care of
initializing these variables
yourself.
So as an NDK developer, also
there are other performance
considerations and tools and
stuff available for you
because it can get tricky.
And it's not easy to manage
memory when you're writing the
memory, handling things
yourself.
So you need to be
extra careful.
So what we have as part
of tools and IDEs--
the ADT 20 IDE now supports
NDK building and debugging
directly from using
the ADT plug-in.
And this actually uses a
multi-threaded GDB, so you
don't have to write all the
codings like main thread to be
able to debug that.
There's a link to that,
tools.android.co
m/recent/usingthendkplugin, and
this is where you can see
notes about the support and
how to configure it.
There are also plug-ins
available, Eclipse plug-ins
available from [? Nmedia ?]
that can help you do performance
and memory
analysis for your application.
We also support the NDK GDB,
which is the GNU debugger that
you can use.
And you can use any GDB.
So this actually starts a GDB
server on your device and then
uses a name [? byte ?] to talk
to your machine that you're
debugging it from.
So these are some of the
tools available.
There are a lot more available
from community.
There are a number of us who
have come up with complete
project generation kits.
And so the companies like
[? Nmedia ?] have come up with
advanced memory analysis
tools and stuff.
So this is some of the things
you can explore.
And each time you use this, you
should always debug your
applications using Gingerbread
because you can debug a
NativeActivity, find out new
[? polls ?], find out memory
leaks and fix them.
So yeah.
That brings us to the end
of the presentation.
We will now move on to Q and
A. Ankur, do you want
to take that up?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
Thanks, Anirudh.
So we have Anatoliy live.
Hi, there.
ANATOLIY KAVERIN: Yeah.
Hi.
Do you hear me well?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah,
we can hear you.
ANATOLIY KAVERIN: OK.
Great.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Do you have
any questions that you
wanted to ask us?
ANATOLIY KAVERIN: Yeah.
Just a question regarding NDK.
I'm glad that you're
in the session.
Actually, as a topic, this
is the first Hangout I'm
attending to.
And I was not aware
of the topic.
But NDK is actually right
now one of my projects.
I'm working closely with it.
So the first question is--
you said that there are some
header files we each provide
to NDK developers.
What about STL?
Something related to more
language, I would say.
Are they stable?
I know that there are
three alternatives.
No, not three but two.
It's [INAUDIBLE]
and [INAUDIBLE], which we
can use in our projects.
But are they stable or not?
Because it mentions them
in the list of
the available headers.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: So the libraries
that I've mentioned
in the list of available
headers, these are more stable
ones and guaranteed to work
across each of the releases.
So these are the ones
[INAUDIBLE]
as far as Android [INAUDIBLE]
is concerned.
Or the Android system library
set is concerned, you can
always have your third party
libraries there.
But from the [? systemic ?]
perspective, the ones
[INAUDIBLE].
And you can always find the
updated list on the
developer.google.com NDK.
Actually, we have a list
of libraries there.
And you should always
stick to that.
ANATOLIY KAVERIN: But as far as
I know, some STL libraries
are shipped with NDK.
But they are not
stable, right?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Anirudh, just
before you answer the next
question-- we can't
see you, actually.
Your screen share is still on.
There you go.
Thank you.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Thanks.
I'm sorry.
You said, some libraries--
I didn't catch which libraries.
Some?
ANATOLIY KAVERIN: I mean that
STL is a part of NDK.
But it is not listed in
the stable libraries.
So they ship together, but they
are not still stable?
Right?
They are subject to change.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: I think
there's a [INAUDIBLE]
string that we had.
I can check and get back to you
whether we want to call it
stable and make it available
and really want to call it
stable officially.
So that you can go
ahead and use it.
I know it's available
as far as the NDK.
Maybe I'll get back on
this [INAUDIBLE]
this Hangout and post
an answer there.
ANATOLIY KAVERIN: OK.
And Just a second question
regarding NativeActivity.
Imagine that I'm developing
some application where I'm
going to have audio and
video streaming.
For example, this will be
something similar to what
we're doing now, Hangout,
targeted on
primary full tablets.
And for example, in one part
of the screen I'm going to
have, for example,
some video frame.
In another part, I'm going to
have some chat and of course
audio conversation.
Will NativeActivity benefit
me somehow?
Because as I see it now, I was
planning to use, I would say,
a classic Java activity with
some framing with video
output, for example.
But my audio/video compression
code already is a part of NDK
library, which I'm shipping
with my application.
So do I have any benefits if I
will stick to NativeActivity?
Will it benefit me in the
performance of this, I would
say, video showing,
video output?
Can you comment?
ANIRUDH DEWANI: So if you are
using any of those specific
instructions--
the Neon instruction
set, et cetera--
for your compression routines
and stuff, you may have some
benefits in performance there.
But otherwise, largely,
it's part of--
as far as rendering and stuff
is concerned on the
screen, there is--
I really wouldn't say that
there's any benefit in using
the NDK for that stuff.
So yeah.
It's really up to the
compression and all that
routines, plus computationally
intensive routines.
And if you want to take some
benefit there using the
instruction set [INAUDIBLE]
available on the [INAUDIBLE],
that's where [INAUDIBLE].
ANATOLIY KAVERIN: OK.
OK.
Thank you.
So far I've got no
more questions.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Ankur,
we cannot hear you.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Well, that's
embarrassing.
I was talking for good 30
seconds then on mute.
In terms of moderator, we have
one question on there.
Which basically says, "How do
I send search terms to the
Google search app built into
Android?" I mean, the answer
to this is typically--
what you do is you'd just call
a URL, like doing a normal
Google search.
You will actually not go through
the Google search app.
It'll basically fire
up your browser.
And you'll get search results
through the webpage, the
mobile site.
So I guess my follow-up question
to this would be, is
there anything in particular
that you are after in that
built in Google search app?
Because in general, that
Google search app is
basically--
all it is is a user interface
for doing searches.
On Jellybean, we added Google
Now, which actually handles
some Google searches there and
presents them slightly
differently.
But if you do the same search
through your mobile browser,
you do get the same knowledge
cards and the usual results.
And they're kind of formatted to
match your screen size, and
it goes through the browser.
The browser is there.
You don't need to go directly
to the Google search app.
So in terms of your results,
it should be the same.
But I'll be interested to know
what else you might be after,
why specifically you want the
integration with the Google
search app itself.
So JJ from Cambridge, if you're
able to respond back in
a future moderator, that
would be great.
Just let us know.
Let me just see if there's
anything else from the thread
where we've got the
Hangout running.
And there isn't.
So we're done, I guess.
There is nothing
more for today.
Thanks Anirudh for the
presentation on NDK.
I'm sure you'll get quite a few
questions from developers.
It's a fairly common and popular
topic about coding
using C++ for Android.
So thanks very much.
And yeah.
We'll be back next week.
And next week we'll be back to
our regularly scheduled time,
which is on Thursdays.
So yeah.
Thanks for joining us.
And we'll see you next week.
ANATOLIY KAVERIN:
Looking forward.
Bye.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Thanks.
Bye bye.